E aí
o assunto e eu quero mesmo Ser
Reconhecido assim Ricardo riscas
E aí
o Olá boa tarde meu nome é Ricardo
riscas tem que ter dois anos e sou
natural de espinho aqui perto
vende construir um a minha paixão que se
chama lá que estragos
e a Isto é um símbolo e o que me
apaixona na Black Stripes é a construir
guitarras únicas e exclusivas a partir
de materiais
reutilizados e usados como puderam ver
no vídeo aqui tá que estava a ser tocada
por cinco tive foi construída por mim
aquilo era uma caixa de vinhos
portuguesa
para ser um desafio e os styx ir para
quem não tem não conheço é normal que
que é um músico um pouco independente
mas é um músico de 71 anos que tem uma
carreira A Fabulosa a pessoa que fugiu
de casa aos 14 anos por causa dos abusos
com a família mas hoje em dia é um
grande senhor tá com sentimento com João
Paulo Jones dos Led Zeppelin Teve teve
no Turu com ele portanto hoje em dia
realmente conseguiu afirmar-se e estar
em grandes palcos e eu comecei tanto
conseguir arrasar quatro anos e e a
minha primeira guitarra
como é que tava muito simples e a
pergunta que eu faço é que se achavam
que eu há quatro anos e a sonhar em
realmente ter uma guitarra nas mãos um
músico como se estive
sem resposta é
drinque o Arcade System Fox esse Rangers
Of The Good people cento e se em uma
frase que muitos nós alguns e vários
sítios mas que aquela porque achei que
era resumo um carinho meu percurso e
aquilo que eu acredito no projeto da Lei
das leis a dengue porque realmente há
quatro anos fiz esta guitarra e vou
pegar ela novamente Esse é o dia está
aqui na na outra orgulho muito das a
construção dela foi pode ser um amigo
uma prenda de natal e perfeito mas eu
hoje em dia olho para ela e vejo
realmente que é um bocadito foi indicado
feitas pancadas não é assim um cadinho
uma forma simples mas na altura que ele
fez sentido para mim eu queria descobrir
como é que se formos a ver e vai fazer
algo simples para ele e aquele bichinho
de construir guitarras e e sem ter que
podia melhorar a construção e podia
continuar a fazer melhor
desafio me então o sonho
foi crescendo não é eu sonho realmente
foi editar editar acabou por ganhar
fazer sentido começar conseguir as
melhores de um dia realmente fazer
chegaram a guitarra de coisa por mim a
um músico que eu admirasse também tanto
e assim sucedeu a cada todo um episódio
eu vou contar a ser um bocadinho por
alto o episódio que foi conhecer os
estive e fazer chegar uma guitarra com
certeza para mim as mãos dele e o
telhado de uma forma o pessoal
dentro ele foi convidado por aqui de
cara o festival paredes de Coura a
frente e cá em Portugal é na vila
minhota de Coura E aí eu decidi logo a
partir do momento em que realmente sou o
que ele vinha alguma coisa pronto comer
tudo e logo apaga comprar bilhete quero
ver o homem que realmente tem um música
Eu admiro e a música também toca com
guitarras muito especiais são guitarras
também cigarro vou citar se etapas com
feitas 200 de carros guitarras uma corda
só que tentaram música Eu já segui então
que eu não sou que ele vinha cá decidi
fazer alguma coisa e criar um desafio
para mim próprio de construir uma
guitarra para ele então decide ir
O que é que o que é que eu podia fazer
eu já tinha guitarras também construídas
na forma única e exclusiva para outras
pessoas e por ele próprio eu decidi
fazer uma guitarra com produtos
portugueses que é aqui tá renda castanho
porque no fundo
depois desafios todo tipo de ações da
guitarra com caixa de vinho português
que eu vim do ribatejo
também tenho moedas portuguesas que uma
moeda de 50 centavo 50 escudos aqui uma
de vinte centavos portanto e outras
peças têm aqui um galo Barcelos EA
pesquisas assim alguns detalhes para ti
foi a forma que encontrei de me
diferenciar e fazer uma guitarra de uma
forma diferente então foi todo um
Aventura
e o processo entre saber que ele vinha
cá e então focar naquilo e desencontro a
ele e já como é que está feita não é
portanto aqui vai eu
não parei de chorar realmente depois
tive a oportunidade foi com amigos Neve
toda aquela toda aquela aventuras um
festival e já que a gente apronta na na
bagagem lá fui eu
e uma forma natural encontrei-o no
relvado para pagar nem conhece o
festival e os Animais a um cadinho ao
lado da só fica lá com ela mergulhos no
Rio e bastante interessante e ele
apareceu de uma forma Supernatural lá
passear também eu na verdade já tinha
alguns contatos até a última não tinha
confirmado a questão da de conseguir
entregar a guitarra não mas foi o
desafio meter-me no carro com amigos e
disse vais vai ter que acontecer alguma
forma e está arranjar uma maneira de
estude se tornar possível pronto mas ela
está se for sempre isso mas a verdade é
que foi um frango Supernatural ele veio
passear naturalmente pelo pelo jardim e
agora eu tinha aqui uma coisa para te
oferecer pronto e esse Foi um momento
estava como também a quarta que elas
perguntarem estar Ela ali no relvado foi
que ele disse que não podia levar a
guitarra com ele naquela altura mas não
contacto para enviar por correio Por que
ele ia estar em tour E então complicada
questão das bagagens
portanto toda esta aventura para além do
facto de ele
deu um bocado interessante no entanto os
corpos ali
se esta Aventura realmente não foi se
propriamente Só o facto de estar de
conhecer os estive nem tocar não sei se
estive mas sim no fundo o desafio e o
meu sonho foi realmente fazer uma
guitarra que fosse digna de estar nas
mãos de um músico como eu e Isso
realmente é que o meu desafio
equilac.com bom estar com ele eram
Realmente foi um casal cereja no topo do
bolo que se costuma dizer não é pronto
mas toda esta Aventura de paredes que
era foi muito bom para ela que estragos
também não é porque realmente se para
além desta iniciativa telegrama de ter
conseguido concretizar aquilo que eu
propus fazer Foi ter conhecido essas
pessoas que várias pessoas que não
conhecer o projeto com podem ver a essas
pessoas e a área eu nicho que realmente
que está de acordo com os tipos de
Estacas coisas novas e
e como podem ver foi ouvir essas pessoas
a experimentarem as guitarras foi um
enorme desejo escolhi as fotografias
mais engraçadas não podem parar por quê
que realmente é curioso mas não está no
está só apenas as mais pronto é curioso
a posição em que ela quis tirar a
fotografia mas realmente essa
experiência de estar no festival várias
pessoas a acreditar os mais
imprensa também achou uma piada ao facto
de deste desafio desta história e também
deu atenção de um carinho tempo de
antena em alguns canais e outros canais
tanto a nível na internet como nas redes
sociais com em vídeo estou sua mãe que
ela vamos aproveitar um bocadinho essa
história que eu agradeci com uma obra
não é mas realmente foi foi super
importante e para a marca marca cresceu
bastante a marca quer dizer o a
visibilidade que das minhas guitarras
acabaram por crescer imensa porque a
mente foi foi uma rampa de lançamento
e foi esta esta enorme Aventura depois
disso já realmente o conselho se estive
já não aos da do dia não é pronto para
os outros dias tive houveram mas este
Realmente foi um dia muito importante na
no festival para mim eu
vou passar então aqui outra outra parte
que é questão do trabalhar o Arcade que
no fundo assim a esta o sonho é uma
coisa importante eu sonho é realmente
faz nos
criar etapas maiores e saímos um
bocadinho da nossa zona de conforto mas
ganhe até a trabalhar e aprender com o
trabalho diário a que realmente as
coisas pois aquela de fazer sentido
eu vou passar aqui também um bocadinho
de aproveitou passar um bocado do vídeo
Tá constando da guitarra o trabalho é
uma coisa de construir terras aquela
obter tu fizesse bastante interessante e
eu gosto mais que me acabei de ver com o
início é isso acabei de
disse Por que construir a meter as mãos
um material a desenvolver a pesquisar
materiais procura deles é realmente é
esse aqui é o verdadeiro prazer deste
projeto e portanto é desde o construção
de um braço que é que feito combater com
madeiras
e aproveitadas algumas mobiliários
antigos coisas que a mente de tenham
ainda qualidade as caixas são caixas de
neste caso foi caixa de vinho conseguir
encontrar a porque também faz sentido
Não é um produto nacional e essas e
taxas acabam por já tem uma história que
cigarro vou citar são militares têm o
século e tal e ela surgiram um pouco da
Necessidade
que havia na altura no sul do Estados
Unidos de terem instrumentos de verão
pessoas pobres não tinham nada e tá
pensando em construir as suas próprias
ser próprios instrumentos e sempre para
se divertirem para trocar emprestar em
grupo e assim surgiu a chegar a vou
citar se
tanto os materiais que nos rodeiam e
aquilo que nos rodeia acaba por ser
essencial na minha perspectiva e para a
efetiva da Black Stripes para a
construção das guitarras a
é o caso das Caixas As madeiras pois as
ferragens também já me viram ali cortar
um uma chave né também para adaptar
peças da própria guitarra e a construção
destas guitarras não são propriamente
não está propriamente planeado não é não
é um problema de um plano e um desenho
Inicial Isto é cada construção acaba por
ser a única por por isso mesmo por ser
um processo de exploração de vários da
caixa que tem tomadas medidas depois de
muito encontrar peças específicas também
para que façam sentido também na
construção e na estética que eu procuro
depois nas guitarras
Depois tem e depois é a cada nova toda
uma evolução
dessa primeira guitarras que fiz até
agora esta guitarra que eu fiz para você
assistir que foi a última interessante o
que a primeira é uma coisa super básica
agora já me preocupa e os detalhes do
braço já me preocupo nos detalhes da
localidade da guitarra eu quero no fundo
fazer guitarras que façam que tem um som
feito por um mutante um música que
esteja da família sacolas como músico já
que já toca muitos anos e que realmente
quer um instrumento que qualidade e que
leva para o palco e que leva esteja em
concertos com ela
direto aqui na fase final né do da fase
a construção
de toda a fazer o processo do trabalhar
a árvore a cada esta aprendizagem no
fundo de estarmos presentes e estarmos
envolvidos com aquele que nós gostamos
de fazer aquilo que eu quero fazer que
as guitarras e só ali Ah que realmente
consigo fazer sentido todas as ideias e
tudo o projeto é esse e agora aqui final
que diz assim Natal deixa-se lá o
registo do que é que não portanto
mas obviamente trabalho importante sem
dúvida acho que é a parte mais
importante porque é onde se consolida
aquilo que nós queremos fazer mas se não
fizermos as coisas
e
se não fizermos as coisas com amor não é
no fundo e é isso que o também a cabo
e tem que tem que acontecer ele essas
pessoas que são muito específicas o
cuidado com os detalhes o cuidado com os
materiais que vivemos Apesar sem
materiais usados mas são nobres também
não é porque as coisas super super
bonitas que estão que estão vão ficando
encostados né No que nós vamos comprar
coisas novas vamos temos coisas novas e
faz sentido às vezes né porque mas há
coisas que ainda são possíveis
aproveitar e ele fazer as coisas com
o amor acaba por melhorar o nosso o
aspecto do nosso trabalho e
eleva também valoriza aquilo que fazemos
em uma perspectiva Geral do que é que
pode ser
trabalhar com uma agora
e o facto de fazer as coisas com cuidado
e com atenção e amor faz com que também
os resultados e os detalhes das peças
também e sejam curiosos e tenham coisas
que realmente de marca em pela diferença
poder simplesmente e como já existem as
guitarras comuns toda a gente conhece
Hoje em Dia com a internet essa é fácil
comprar um kit pra comprar esse vídeo
chega a casa nós temos o kit se Montamos
uma chave parafuso etc nas próximas
acabamento o prazer de fazer a guitarra
se calhar não é a mesma coisa não é
então aqui a uma intensa estar nesta
guitarra Aproveitei um rótulo de uma
garrafa de gim que é portanto esta está
na cabeça da guitarra e usei-a para
achei piada realmente o rótulo um rótulo
de um gigante u e
então decidi porta chave passei umas
dobradiças também ali na parte de baixo
eu saí apontar com este não
se não fosse a a
e
para tua própria ali um Picape também
tem um rótulo de uma garrafa de vodka
esta guitarra guitarra Monte Cristo essa
guitarra tenho aqui comigo
algumas guitarras que eu já não tenho
porque quando fui as vendendo não é
felizmente e sair da academia Até
precisava
demonstrar já que são a demonstração não
é aquela Demonstrar um bocadinho a
sonoridade que elas são ao vivo
e também guitarra feita com uma caixa de
charutos tem um fiz um F acaba por ter
uma função acústica também a chave que é
uma peça que eu acho fundamental
fundamental funcionalmente a importante
ter esta ponte mas também acho bonito e
acham perfeitamente interessante desse
material tem um puxador também puxador
de gavetas serve perfeitamente para
fazer aqui até o PIS e os também é são
puxadores de gavetas um bocadinho mais
me mais mas que ela pedirá uma loja de
guitarras em comprar o volume mas aqui
acho muito mais piada que as coisas
sejam feitas desta forma
as vagas isto pessoa
E aí
e
eu nem vou largar aqui muito mas quando
já dá para perceber aqui A Celebridade
que ela tem
ah ah ah
e
portanto esta é outra guitarra também
tem o mesmo modelo ali com f não é que a
mãe acústico uma caixa mais viva uma cor
mais mais forte acho que eu tenho aqui
são coisa assim mais neutras de madeira
básicas não é o fundo mas eu gosto deste
deste modelo também do ver o veio da
madeira
Mas esta aqui depois assim essas essas
características muito interessantes com
estas Cores Vivas ir à noite esta
estética da Caixa acaba por ser bastante
criada por estiverem a caixa de charutos
perdidas lá em casa por isso podem me
contactar também
e essa é a outra gritar eu também tenho
aqui e Na altura foi alguma alguma das
guitarras que
com a evolução das minhas construções
achei que realmente Cheguei cheguei a
uma fase e Pacus gosta guitarra acho que
está bem construída e pronto e realmente
também poderíamos desenvolver mostrar um
bocadinho som que ela tem
e
elas esta guitarra também tem os
detalhes curiosos né que já podem ficar
um pouco à semelhança da anterior você
não tem computador a chave aqui leva são
Conchas marítimas né que vai ter para
fazer os elege as marcações também o
corte uma chave madeira também era
mamadeira de um móvel antigo meu lateral
de uma cama que Aproveitei não deve
cortar né se calhar mas depois todo o
processo que o braço constam do braço
que me viram portanto para ser feito por
mim e manualmente
E aí
é
obrigado a
E aí
e
eu também tenho alguns toques e eles não
é também gosto de cara e também gozar me
Casa das pizza de construir e depois
usar as guitarras né mas na verdade acho
que tenho que passar a bola do músico e
de quem tocar aos outros no fundo eu
quero um preocupar no mais da construção
e melhorar a construção plantamos aqui
já agradeci uma forma geral alguns
detalhes das construções e daquilo que
eu vou fazendo um
o Cabral tanto
mantermos o foco citei Félix não é que é
aquela parte essencial e quando se está
num projeto não é para também balizarmos
aquilo que pretendemos fazer porque
assim convites tem sujidade que eu estou
cá hoje ou preferia estar na minha
oficina ali enfiada a explorar várias
formas de construir dará tava muito mais
tranquila ouvir a minha música mas
também é verdade também é importante
aceitar a e encontrar novos desafios e
também esse faz-nos crescer e faz
crescer que eu também temos a fazer mas
principalmente o foco e uma foco é
melhorar e aperfeiçoar aquilo que o nome
é de construção e isso eu quero sempre
fazer a gente vêtements o que queria
levar a marca para a frente e de querer
que as construções também cheguem a mais
pessoas mas isso é uma foco e
é com a nesta é com este prazer é com
este lugar confortável que o encontro às
vezes apetece-me nessa lá uma volta de
vestir o passear e vez de construir mas
na verdade eu tenho ser peso foco que é
queria construir e a professora que a
minha construção e gostar desse ter
prazer com isso e realmente devia
passear dia às vezes nesta fase desses
tive foi no verão é certeza a gente ia
para a praia ligamos a gritar né que
está Já tô aqui na oficina Então isto
não vai demorar mais umas horitas então
era sei lá eram duas da manhã quando já
a praia já estava em fora de planos não
é tanto acho que realmente
existência é algo tem que ser tido em
conta não é um projeto assim e Alex
Street está aqui portanto
duas imagens eu e o início não é no
fundo do
rabiscar uma ideia do depois da primeira
guitarra que eu fiz eu decidi o que é
isto aqui é capaz tem a fazer isto no
fundo foi acabou por ser um algo que eu
que realmente resumiu Várias Vários
Prazeres que eu tinha e então decidi
Então vamos fazer isso mais a sério
então comecei a buscar umas ideias uns
nomes uma no papel no fundo nós todos
temos as nossas ideias várias ideias
criar uma nuvem de ideias e a guerra
buscamos e ficar temos o caderno em
cheio de coisas lado escritas
e está aqui é um exemplo né quiser
acabou por ganhar forma essa
persistência e levou a que as primeiras
coisas estivessem um objetivo eu ganhar
forma e agora a singu mais oficial com o
senhor de barbas Compridas e que o fundo
simples um bocadinho Close a forma
relaxada de estar na vida
e
aqui o sabe onde é o céu gago de pipa na
cadeira que ela pertence ao estarmos
rodeados por pessoas que estamos se
pessoas que nos fazem sentir bem e
confortável e confortáveis e no fundo
alexar surgiu a pronto interpessoal e
surgiu através da minha da minha vontade
de querer fazer uma prenda para um amigo
como eu já disse já está ali um amigo é
uma pessoa que realmente
quiser que uma forma se colateral sem
ele fazer nada por isso mas vamos estava
ajudar porque no fundo ele para
cá eu aprendi a ele então eu decidi
fazer aprenda Mas a partir dali toda
todo o conjunto pessoas sem presente
estar à nossa volta como pessoas
talentosas criativas pessoas que que
tenham aumento abertas que também nos
ajudem na nossa paixão que acredita
naquilo que nós queremos fazer também às
vezes obviamente não é Bruno Vamos ouvir
sempre o que exigiam os anos ouvir a
resolvido coisas que não queremos mas
também é importante é porque não é é que
nós vamos perceber também o que é que
nós queremos geralmente ser aquilo que
queremos não é aquilo que eu sei aquilo
realmente que é o nosso principal é um
desafio é
o
PT que fazer uma pequena brincadeira que
está Grande Otelo meio da good people E
é isso que eu pretendo E é isso que eu
tenho que fazer é acreditar pessoas que
no fundo apesar de ser um trabalho feito
em principal dentro de uma oficina este
todo o trabalho da marca lá que strife a
cabeça de muitas pessoas e ter pessoas
que me acompanham pessoas que trocam as
militar as pessoas que gozam e que
vestem A camisola
e isto Só se consegue também dando dando
um bocadinho aos outros né eu ia
aproveitar então não sei isto os minutos
estão já mas por que aproveitar aquilo
que chama o amigo só para ficar um
bocadinho já que estamos a demo já ela
está isto esse eu fui um cadinho
improvisar né mas eu já sabe que isto
pode sempre acontecer
em que a gente pode mostrar aquilo
estamos a falar
se você já daqui
em contraste aí o não sei construir
guitarras não sabe tocar mesmo esse
acaba ser uma ãh
é mas é só um bocadinho tá bem né
E aí
O
Ricardo é
o Ricardo EA também um desses meus
amigos que me acompanha nessas aventuras
Apesar assim ter nada a ver com ele né
no fundo ele tem o vida dele mas quando
quando calha a vira dar uma mãozinha Lá
vem ele com todo gosto também gosta
dessas coisas né pronto agora para
terminar também é para terminar essa já
terminou não é no fundo e queria
agradecer já vou cortar ele agradecer a
fazer essa e eu convite está bem muito
obrigado até bosta e
E aí